Farm safety net programs were
established to protect agricultural
producers against production, price, and
income risks. But payments for major
federal programs like agricultural risk
coverage, price loss coverage, and crop
insurance overwhelmingly go to the
wealthiest and largest farms. The top 10%
of farms by total crop sales, which have
an average net worth of 5.5 million,
received $55,000 in payments per farm in
2015,
totaling almost $3 billion, or nearly
two-thirds of all program payments. The
other 90% of farms received just four
thousand dollars on average. Two recent
proposals attempt to limit the
concentration in subsidies. A $40,000 cap
on crop insurance subsidies would save
an estimated two billion dollars per
year, while $125,000 cap on per-farm subsidies across all programs, would
save $670 million per year. Nearly all of
these savings come from a reduction in
payments to the largest 5% of farms, who
are the least vulnerable to adverse
market conditions. In order for these
programs to provide an effective safety
net, they need to be targeted at the most
vulnerable.
So what do you think the farm
safety net program should look like in
the United States? Let us know in your
comments. Also, let us know what other
topics you'd like our scholars to cover
in 60 seconds, and be sure to LIKE and
subscribe for more research and videos
from AEI.